so I guess this brings a question then
of how far can the Fed go right so
you've got kind of on an amount
standpoint and then you also have do we
start to see them go into buying stocks
do they buy indexes do they actually
start playing kingmaker on individual
stocks like how far can these programs
go both in size and scope they can go as
far as they want I think what we got to
keep in mind let's talk about where
they're not going right now
they've pretty much done everywhere
except hide yield they will by fallen
Angelz March 22nd they announced that
they'd by corporate bonds and then they
announced time last week that they will
now buy any investment grade corporate
bond that lost its investment great
status after March 22nd so March 25th
Ford got downgraded to junk they're
eligible for the Fed to buy March 20th
Occidental Petroleum got downgraded to
junk sorry oxy you're not going to be
blocked by the Fed and so that's kind of
where they've drawn that line and
they're not buying equities why are they
hesitant to go there I think there's a
simple reason when you start owning
high-yield there's a very good chance
that you're going to be involved in a
restructuring that's running the company
that means that one said about holders
thinks that we should restructure the
company this way another set of
bondholders thinks we should restructure
the company that way
they said you own some of these bonds
you get a vote which way we're going to
go the Fed doesn't want to be in that
place and they don't want to be running
companies that's why they don't want to
own equities they don't want to have to
vote the slate of candidates for the
Board of Directors they will come under
enormous you know just to get the point
across if the Fed owns equities and then
it's our and then it's a proxy voting
season you can see AOC on the floor of
the house going I think I should have to
help you guys decide which directors
that these companies should be voting in
and that's why they don't want to go
there so ETF's
yes sure you could be involved in the
ownership of the fund management company
that manages ETF nobody cares about that
but you know could they lead into buying
spiders sure they could lead into that
but I think it would be a big
for the Fed in order to buy equities or
go straight into high-yield itself
because then they're gonna get into
management companies I'm not discounting
that they won't do it I'm just saying
that I think that you know I've argued
on Twitter and stuff like that I think
it's a possibility that they do it but
first the SPS probably got to make a new
low
offer below it's March 23rd low and they
got a feel under tremendous amounts of
pressure
how far can they go you know money-wise
Paula said it and he's right
boy they they could put up a big
infinite number in front of that if they
need to I think more the question
becomes will that work because
ultimately you got to ask the question
of Eric Peters one River asset
management wrote over the weekend if the
Fed eliminated all their programs the
stock market would probably fall 50% 50%
off its high it's down about a quarter
so we go back to the below the March
23rd gloves it's probably not wrong on
that meaning that the Fed is
artificially supporting the market at a
level it wouldn't be as I like to joke
I'm pointing at my Bloomberg right now
if a little red headline came across my
Bloomberg Jay Paul changes his mind
cancels all the programs what do you
think the stock market would do tomorrow
it beat down a zillion points and so if
the Fed is holding the market it
artificial levels can it do it forever
and I think the answer is no I think
they could do it for a while because
they've got a lot of money with an
infinite printing press but ultimately
whatever we perceive is fair value and
if that is lower that weight will
eventually come down on the market and
push it back down one more time so yeah
they could keep going and they could
keep trying but if the markets at the
wrong level even an infinite printing
press cannot keep it there forever for a
while yes but not forever yeah it almost
feels like a lot of the stock market
movement right now are pure speculation
based on Federal Reserve announcements
and programs and all this kind of stuff
and almost like selling the hope that
hey they can get us out of this but I do
think that one of the reality checks is
gonna be that first you know real big
set of earnings reports that come out
where people show
you know hey our revenues down 70% right
and yeah our stock fell 25 percent but
that 25% haircut Li took it we're still
overvalued based on the revenue yeah
right and you start to get some kind of
you know at least an acknowledgment or a
highlight of the dislocation between the
speculation in the markets versus the
reality that a lot of these companies
and I was talking to a buddy who's a an
accountant been doing it for a long time
and and he literally said to me this
morning he goes I I haven't seen this
level of financial carnage that I've
seen in the last three weeks ever in my
career right he usually is dealing with
kind of you know small to medium sized
businesses you know nothing kind of
corporate or public companies and so if
that's what's happening on the you know
kind of everyday Main Street you got to
imagine at some point that reality
actually sets in an investor's mind so
what as well
yeah I agree you know if you actually
look at this week yawn hot C's at
Goldman Sachs and Mike Wilson and Morgan
Stanley basically they abandoned their
bearish calls saying that the low is in
place on March 23rd and the markets
going to go higher reason one
the feds ultimate printing press so
that's not like a fundamental reason or
the economy is getting better it's just
that you know if somebody keeps hitting
me in the face $100 bills enough that
maybe I'll change my behavior and that's
exactly what they're betting on that
that's going to happen it might work at
a strip club but I'm not sure it works
for the entire market in general as well
- and so that's what's really pushing it
as far as the carnage goes you're right
the Peter Brook fire mentioned you gotta
watch the balance sheets and I think
he's exactly right for the following
reason if your company reports the 70%
loss of revenue revenue you are taking a
giant loss and you aren't losing capital
you are not just going to have a revenue
you just didn't have a minute on your
earnings your capital position is going
to be impaired by that size of loss it's
going to affect the structure of your
balance sheet that takes a while to fix
you know because you're not going to
have you know like the old saying goes
when when we go back you're not going to
get two haircuts and eat three dinners
you know those are gone and that revenue
is not going to be all we're playing
all at once so you're gonna impair
balance sheets and that's going to
create time in order to see how long
it's going to take him that's what I
think we got a watch in this earnings
report
I think book first got it right it's not
that we're gonna watch yeah we know the
earnings numbers are gonna be horrific
but how much did you impair the balance
sheet I think that's what your
accountant friend was talking about is
that people's businesses one under and
they're drawing against their life
savings to keep them going and they're
at real risk of financial ruin here even
though everybody says this will be
temporary and will go away and
everything will be okay